putin denkt wie jeder diktator alles was
ihm hilft an der macht zu bleiben wird
er auch machen menschen umbringen
blutvergießen in andere länder angreifen
internationale verträge brechen
ich finde schwierig leute die in der
freien welt geboren sind zu erklären
dass demonstrieren in russland ein
großes risiko darstellt garri kasparow
war und ist der berühmteste spieler der
welt
[Musik]
garri kasparow er in den ersten zehn
jahren von putins herrschaft einer der
aktivsten gegner des starken mannes in
moskau ob ich angst habe ja ich mache
mir sorgen aber was kann ich dagegen tun
ich kann ja nicht einfach aufhören zu
sagen was ich schon seit jahren sage das
ist eine frage der ehre wenn russland
frei ist
warum menschen wie mich braucht werde
ich bereit sein russland wird meine
hilfe und die hilfe vieler die heute im
exil leben brauchen und zurück in den
kreis zivilisierte nation zu bilden
[Musik]